every day we are unwavering in our
focus to protect life and keep our
nation
safe from this deadly virus and today
i'd like to
bring you up to speed on some new
developments in our response
and start with the latest data the
latest data show
that the number of cases of coronavirus
are rising
yesterday we saw 3542
new cases the highest since the 12th of
april
the variant first identified in india
so called b1617.2
is still spreading and the latest
estimates
are that more than half and potentially
as many as
three quarters of all new cases
are now of this variant
now as we set out our road map we always
expected
cases to rise we must remain vigilant
the aim of course is to break the link
to hospitalizations and deaths so that
cases alone
no longer require stringent
restrictions on people's lives the
critical thing to watch is the link
from the number of cases to how many
people end up
in hospital the increase in cases
remains focused
in hot spots and we're doing all we can
to tackle this variant
wherever it flares up over the past six
months
we now have built a huge testing
capacity
at our disposal and we're
using this to surge testing into the
eight hot spot areas
and in other places where cases are
lower
but rising in the hot spot areas we're
surging vaccines too for those who are
eligible
in bolton for instance we've done 17
147 vaccinations in the last week
all of the available evidence shows that
the best way to protect
yourself your loved ones and your
community
against this new variant is to get both
jabs of the 49 people who are in
hospital
with covert in bolton only five
have had both vaccine doses
and earlier today i spoke to fiona
nowden the chief executive of bolton
hospital
and her message is very clear the
is functioning well and is open to all
those who need it
but people need to be careful and
cautious
and follow the rules and take personal
responsibility
to help to slow the spread she also said
that and i quote
i dread to think where we'd be without
the vaccine
so please ask people to come forward and
get the jab
so when you get the call get the jab
and make sure you come forward for your
second dose
so you can get the maximum possible
protection
the vaccine is severing the link between
cases and hospitalizations
and deaths from coronavirus this week's
ons data show that three and four adults
now have covered 19
antibodies including over 90 percent of
people aged 50 and above
and this means that the vast majority of
those most vulnerable
to this virus have that protection that
antibodies provide
but i want to see those rates climb
further having three in four adults
with antibodies is important but there's
more still
to do and today's data from public
health england
show why this is important they have
estimated that over the last week
the vaccination program has prevented a
further 200 deaths
and prevented a further 600 people from
going into hospital
bringing these figures together it means
that in total
13 200 deaths have been prevented and 39
700 hospitalizations by the vaccination
program
so the case for getting the jab has
never been stronger and we're putting
jabs
into arms as quickly as humanly possible
we've given in fact
4.1 million vaccines over the past week
which is the highest figure since march
and i'm absolutely delighted
to see how this is rolling out in
different parts of the country
thanks to the incredible hard work of
colleagues across the midlands
including andy street the mayor of the
west midlands and nhs colleagues
right across the midlands and so many
others we have today hit the milestone
of
10 million vaccines being delivered
across the midlands
in the south west of england where i was
earlier this week visiting vaccination
centers
as far flung as the owls of scilly over
five million doses have been delivered
three-quarters of adults in the
southwest have now had their first dose
and
over half have had both doses this is
the highest proportion in the country
all in all this rapid progress in the
rollout of vaccines in this race between
the virus and the vaccines
this rapid rollout means that yesterday
we were able to open up vaccinations to
all
those aged 30 and above and i would urge
everybody to come forward
next week i'll be hosting g7 health
ministers
at the health ministers summit in oxford
oxford has been at the cutting edge of
science
during this pandemic they led the
recovery trial that uncovered treatments
that have saved millions of lives across
the world
and of course they developed the oxford
vaccine
which is britain's gift to the world
that has now been deployed without any
profit margin
to 450 million doses
across the world today i can update you
that half a million people here
have now signed up to our vaccine
registry
research registry the vaccine research
registry is
about having a group of people who are
prepared to take part
in clinical trials and they've signed up
to say that they're
ready and willing to take part and this
is important because our world leading
position
in the discovery of new medicines relies
on these clinical trials
and i'm incredibly grateful to the half
a million people who are all playing
their part
today i can announce further that
together with sepi
the global vaccination effort we've
funded the expansion of another
important oxford study
which is the first in the world to look
at whether different vaccines can
safely be used as part of a two dose
regime
using different vaccines and if they can
be mixed
then and they can be mixed without
reducing effectiveness
or indeed mixed and lead to an increase
in effectiveness
then this could have a huge impact on
speedy up vaccination campaigns
all the way across the world and getting
more people the protection
that's needed from this deadly virus it
has the potential to transform
lives globally and it is brilliant
frankly to see that once again research
which is taking place on our shores and
at our universities
is leading the way one of the most
promising areas of new research is into
antivirals
the thing about antivirals is that you
can give them to people in an
area of an of an outbreak for instance
to reduce their chance of catching
covert
if they come into contact with somebody
who has got covered
so for instance you can use antivirals
to help suppress an outbreak
these antivirals are not yet approved
and the prime minister has set
a goal of having two available
later this year antivirals can treat
people
early preventing mild disease from
turning into something much more serious
and they can use as a prophylactic
preventing
the virus from spreading i'm absolutely
determined that our
antivirals task force will channel the
same
positive can do collaborative spirit
that works so successfully for vaccines
and i'm pleased to be able to announce
that eddie gray
has been appointed as chair eddie brings
a wealth of experience
from his time at gsk and at
dynavax and i know that eddie will make
a huge
contribution at this time of national
need
our response to this pandemic is a
big team effort and eddie's leadership
will help make that team stronger sill
it's this team this collective endeavor
which you've been a part of
that's got us this far but the pandemic
is not yet
over so please keep doing your bit
remember the basics hands face space
and fresh air get your rapid regular
tests
and when you get the call get both jabs
i